et la russie qui doit faire face à une
nouvelle flambée de 4go vide en cause le
variant delta plus contagieuse c'est
surtout moscou qui est touché mais pas
seulement un rebond que l'on explique
notamment par une vaccination difficile
à mettre en place pour en parler on
retrouve notre correspondant antoine
claireaux à moscou bonsoir toit de la
réussite il vient donc d'atteindre
malheureusement encore une fois un
nouveau record de mortalité quotidienne
oui tout à fait stéphanie en ce mardi la
russie a enregistré un nouveau record de
décès quotidiens duo kobe 19 854
personnes sont mortes ces dernières 24
heures le précédent record qui s'est
élevé à 828 décès remonte à ce monde il
ya quelques jours c'était le 24
septembre dernier vaccination quand elle
vous l'avez évoqué continue de piétiner
à l'heure actuelle un peu moins de 30%
de la population russe est entièrement
vacciner les autorités sanitaires en
conviennent seule une couverture
vaccinale de la population plus
importante pourrait enrayer cette
spirale d'écouté
parmi la population russe adultes 47
millions ont reçu une dose c'est moins
de la moitié
ce n'est pas 60% ce n'est pas 80% donc
pour le moment rien ne laisse à penser
que tout cela va cesser beaucoup de gens
en contact avec le virus vont encore
tomber malade
et malgré cette nouvelle flambée
épidémique et dans les autorités russes
assurent qu'aucune restriction aucun
confinement n'est prévue pour le moment
antoine vous êtes donc un mot ce qu'on
le disait à quoi ressemble la vie
quotidienne est ce qu'il existe malgré
tout les mesures mises en place par les
autorités
oui bien dans la capitale russe à
l'exception de certains événements il
n'existe pas de passer ni terre aucun
passé ni terres ni en vigueur seuls le
port du masque est obligatoire dans les
transports en publics ou encore dans les
lieux fermés qui accueillent du public
comme les restaurants les centres
commerciaux ou encore les magasins par
contre c'était pas forcément le cas
ailleurs en russie en effet chaque
région gère cette problématique en
fonction de sa propre situation
sanitaire dans la ville de perm dans la
chaîne de l'oural dans l'est du pays
enfin à l'est de moscou et bien par
exemple dans cette ville là pour aller
au restaurant il faut présenter un qr
code une preuve de vaccination ou bien
un test pcr négatif merci beaucoup
antoine gayraud en direct de moscou